a group of friends celebrate receiving
their coronavirus vaccinations in new
delhi
they're some of the lucky ones who
managed to get an appointment
signs at many vaccine centers around the
country read
they are out of doses despite having a
population of 20 million people
india's financial capital mumbai only
has 20
000 doses for those between the ages of
18 to 45.
we were told that it would be a
first-come first-served thing here but
the vaccination center here is deserted
we will see what we're going to do
whether we will get it or not
the government said everyone above the
age of 18 would be eligible for a
vaccine from saturday
but most regional leaders say they don't
have enough doses to expand the program
the sign reads welcome to the world's
largest vaccination drive but despite
india being the world's largest vaccine
manufacturer it can't supply
enough doses to its people this is one
of just a handful of private hospitals
in new delhi
that were able to procure vaccines to
inoculate people between the ages of
18 to 45 on saturday the online
registration
also isn't accessible for the hundreds
of millions of indians who don't own
computers or smartphones
and don't have an internet connection
india is
also running short on oxygen despite
international
aid arriving on saturday staff at one
hospital in new delhi said patients had
died including
one of their doctors when an oxygen
delivery was late
amaretto
for god sake please try to organize
oxygen for us
there was a gap of 45 minutes when we
didn't have oxygen
we did everything we could we used all
our cylinders but despite that
we couldn't save six of our icu patients
the death toll later went up to at least
12.
health experts are asking the government
to impose more restrictions to ease the
pressure on the health care system
currently i think the india has to step
up its
containment measures these measures will
have to be very aggressive
and we should also have localized
lockdown wherever necessary
to get at least the transmission
arrested
scientific advisors appointed by the
government say they warned officials in
early march
of a new and more contagious variant of
the coronavirus
despite that the government didn't
impose restrictions
and allowed people to gather at large
political
and religious events elizabeth puranam
al jazeera new delhi